hi good afternoon everyone it's my very
great pleasure to welcome you to our
second company of scholars lecture this
year this is our chance to hear from our
colleagues all the interesting work
that's being that's going on on campus
today we have Emily Greenwood to speak
with us she's a professor of classics
and currently also the director of
undergraduate studies in the department
Emily trained at Cambridge University
receiving her BA I'm Phil and PhD
degrees from Cambridge after which she
was a lecturer in Greek for several
years at st. Andrews University before
joining the Yale faculty in 2009 her
research interests are rooted in ancient
Greek historiography and Greek prose
literature of the fifth and sixth
centuries BCE but she has very
interesting wide-ranging interests that
carry her from ancient times into 20th
century modern times and the influence
of Greek literature on on current events
or current much more current to us
anyway she's the author of two books
lucida teas and shape it the shaping of
history published in 2006 and afro
Greeks dialogues between Anglophone
Caribbean literature and classics in the
20th century which is published in 2010
and for which she was awarded the
runciman prize one of several prizes
she's she's won and she's currently
working on a third book called classics
a beginner's guide and is the author of
many articles uh Emily also taught in
the first melon concentration courses of
course here at Yale that you may be
familiar with and the theme was
technologies of knowledge which she
taught with Francesco Cassidy and the
film and Media Studies department and
with FAS Dean Tamar Gendler of the
philosophy department so today a
professor Greenwood will compare
Thucydides idea of the great war and not
of course as the peloponnesian war with
the figure of the great war in British
prose fiction
and memoirs of the first world war in
her talk how to write awards acidities
and British first world war literature
welcome thank you very much for that
introduction Dean Cooley and I'd like to
thank you and Robin Ladouceur for
organizing this series and for setting
this particular lecture up and above all
warm thanks to the audience here today I
can see many many many busy friends and
colleagues in the audience it's a great
honor to give a company of scholars
lecture and in the spirit of the lecture
series I've chosen a topic that spans
several different disciplines and which
ideally should be tackled by a company
rather than a lone individual scholar so
i'm particularly looking forward to the
discussion after the talk in the era of
the digital humanities I cherished the
quite quaint sounding idea of a company
of scholars whose work is with our own
bodies digitally corporally mentally and
collectively as a more knowing body in
order to conceive of and explore ever
expanding and ever shifting fields of
knowledge thinking about the individual
scholars role in all of this i came
across the term into memory used in
computer science to describe if I
understand it correctly and i quote
large-scale highly survivable and
available storage systems made up of
widely distributed processes that are
individually unreliable or trustworthy
with the overall system nevertheless
secure I don't want to characterize
scholars in the humanities or scholars
in any field as individually unreliable
that would be taking the strategy of
rhetorical self debasement too far but
what I cling to you in that quotation is
the interdependency of different
disciplines it's the bit about the
overall system nevertheless secure that
inspires me today I guess you could also
say that speaking in a company of
scholars series I have a slight perform
anxiety given that the last lecture in
this series was literally given by a
company of scholars the great team of
valerie hansen Mary Miller and Anders
wind off on the FEMA thicker circa 1000
so let me preface what I'm going to say
by offering a bit of background as to
why I've chosen this topic a one-level
it's part of a current project which I'm
calling comparing facilities where I'm
staging a series of dialogues between
facilities and different authors in
antiquity and modernity at another level
the material that I'm presenting today
is part of a larger thinking through of
the narrative structures and historical
myths and by myths I don't mean fictions
as such I mean stories through which
history is transmitted so the narrative
structures and historical myths that we
live by in the 21st century my own and
specifically of course in the case of
this lecture I'm going to be talking
about narrative structures and
historical myths of the First World War
my own first partial and subjective
encounters with a collective memory and
history making the First World War
derived from the 1980s and 90s when i
came across the subject of the First
World War in the school curriculum in
subtle fragmented but persistent ways
the schools I attended in Britain I saw
memorials to the fallen about the school
grounds which inscribed roles of former
pupils who had given their lives in the
great war this was soon followed for me
by the realization that the literature
of the First World War was deadly
serious within this curriculum and in
some sense hallowed at the third school
I attended for example pupils who
misbehaved might be set as punishment
Tennyson's charge of the Light Brigade
the perm of 1854 relating to the Crimean
War and they'd have to memorize it as
punishment or write it out a hundred
times but the literature and the poems
of the First World War would never be
abused in this way the fourth school
that I attended had a very strong
culture of voluntary service an
afternoon a week would be devoted to
service and one got to choose from a
menu of diff
forms of service one of which was an
organization called the combined Cadet
Force CCF this was a program sponsored
by the british ministry of defence i
ended up in the Royal Air Force division
of this combined cadet forces ostensibly
the rationale of this program is was and
is because it still exists is to instill
discipline leadership and strength of
character in students through a soft
introduction to military service I
didn't have any particular affinity for
the Armed Forces at the time but I think
and I'm fully aware of the fal ability
of my own memory in thinking this I
think that I drifted into this combined
Cadet Force because of the solemn
impression of the lists of the Fallen
not to mention monuments in village
greens and town squares as I was growing
up but being taken to a shooting range
and being made to shoot at a silhouette
of a soldier immediately put me off as
did the fact that my afro wouldn't fit
under the beret that was part of our
regulation uniform so I had to cut a
slot in the back of my beret and of
course I promptly failed the first
inspection on parade I've begun with
these vignettes not in any way to claim
familiarity or affinity with the
historical experience of the First World
War as it was experienced by combatants
and civilians I'm talking about Britain
which was just one of many many theatres
and countries horrific experienced by
this war nor if I told these vignettes
to insert myself as an heir to the
legacy of the British experience of the
First World War but rather as an act of
disclosure so as to why I might be
susceptible to the complex politics and
poetics of what a Yale colleague
professor jay winter has termed the
crowded field of the historical
membrance of World War one in the
centennial of the First World War I
think that men and women around the
world in all countries in all of the
countries that were involved in the war
and to a conscious of its vast losses a
wrestling with the burden and the a
pariah the despondency in ampang
ability of memory the app arera of
trying to figure out an appropriate
attitude of memory with regard to the
global war and our relationship with a
past for which we do not exist and in
using that phrase a past for which we do
not exist I'm twisting a famous phrase
of Joseph Brodsky where he spoke about
classical antiquity in the sense that
while antiquity exists for us in
modernity we for antiquity do not in the
context of the centenary observation of
the First World War which has revived
debates about the politics and protocols
of memory in the different countries
affected by the conflict I've often
asked myself what my discipline classics
and specifically the sub-discipline of
Greek historiography knows that might
usefully be part of a larger
conversation about the commemoration of
the First World War recent scholarship
has furnished some excellent answers to
this question had been particularly
inspired for instance by Elizabeth van
Devas work stand in the trench Achilles
classical receptions in British poetry
of the First World War but Greek
historiography hasn't been prominent in
this discussion although in political
thought and international relations
facilities as history is a familiar
companion text for analyzing wars of the
20th century he's used for example as a
dialogue piece for the first and second
world wars the Korean War the Cold War
more generally and the first Gulf War
but when we turned to the literature of
war in the 20th century facilities
hasn't been an obvious presence whether
in Britain or elsewhere in this lecture
I'm not going to try to argue that the
acidity Zyzz an important presence in
British First World War literature
instead I'm going to use a comparison
between a select group of British first
world war novels and memoirs to refocus
the debate on the way in which this
literature negotiates the discredited
greatness of the first war so-called
great war in Britain I'll argue that the
acidities is account of a self-styled
Great War the wall between the Athenians
and the pail
lesions in the fifth century BCE
reinvents the idea of the Great War in
Western literature reacting against the
version of the Great War as epic
familiar from Homer's Iliad and I'll
also argue that a study of the narrative
tropes and linguistic devices that
Thucydides uses to construct his Great
War help to tease out structures of
narrative and meaning in British First
World War literature that are
characterized by disillusionment about
the great warm this dialogue with
acidities adds a supplement to
prevailing arguments that explain the
ironic paradigm in terms of literary
modernism and disillusionment with
contemporary history so I'm going to try
and use the dialogue with you SID ities
to disturb conventional periodization
and ways of explaining how a particular
set of novels are characterized by
disenchantment with the war I should say
as an aside that to focus a topic on the
Great War in a dialogue about the Great
War is of course parochial in many ways
insofar as the nomenclature of the Great
War is used predominantly in Britain
like Hong gars lose far less in France
and divorces Krieg far less in Germany
so it's parochial in that sense but i
think that there's a more generalizable
aspect here in that the underlying
question of the historian graphical
ethics of war writing is one that
applies to the literature and
commemoration of all wars in all places
and particularly how this war literature
navigates the question of a heroic
paradigm of greatness that shifts over
the course of the unfolding of a war to
a tragic paradigm of greatness in
scholarship on British literature of the
First World War the argument this is
that this literature treats greatness as
an ironic construct and a construct that
was ripe for satire is associated above
all with Paul Fussell's work the great
war and modern memory published in
nineteen seventy five since then the
cultural turn and literary studies has
challenged Fussell's argument about the
warez text and his corresponding
attention to the self-consciousness
Rinus of the war in works written
overwhelmingly by men of the officer
class while this challenge and
correction of fossil is important it
hasn't undermined or reversed his
insight that the works that constitute
the Canon and I aware that we're talking
artificially here about a cannon the
works that have come to constitute the
Canon of British First World War
literature subscribed to an ironic
reading of the war is still very much a
current argument I'm not going to tackle
the important debate about the degree to
which these ironic and disillusioned
representations were more broadly
representative of a prevailing tendency
in the collective memory in Britain of
the First World War instead I want to
examine the way in which the ironic mode
links First World War literature in
Britain to a larger metas on ray of
critical war literature and I'm going to
pose affinities and similarities with a
stuck structural conundrum that
Thucydides was faced with in writing up
his war namely how to reconcile an
argument about the greatness of the war
that he was writing in terms of its
scale and importance with the
realization that its greatness was
simultaneously a property of tragedy and
was measured in Los so I've suggested
that in the Western historiographical
tradition Thucydides invents the figure
of the Great War a figure characterized
by an emphasis on the unprecedented
scale and significance of the war being
narrated at the level of narrative this
theater d and Great War is structured
around a colossal reversal of
expectations it's underscored by the
literary trope of irony as I've stared
and stylistically this idea of the Great
War in Thucydides is conveyed through
rhetorical amplification repeatedly
through the use of superlative
adjectives in the description of this
war in fact it's in Thucydides that we
get the idea of the great war as an
inherently comparative figure in the
acidity zehrs case the principal
comparison as I've said is with the
Trojan War of Homeric epic which he
treats as a semi-fictional war
and then the other comparison of course
with Herodotus Herodotus narrative of
the persian wars in the preface to his
histories Herodotus had claimed that one
of his aims and I quote is to preserve
the fame of the important and remarkable
achievements the Ergo Megillah Tekkit o
master produced by both Greeks and
non-greeks ie Herodotus had claimed that
his subject matter was great or
important but not that it was the
greatest subject-matter conceivable
conversely having introduced his subject
matter as a great war facilities quickly
establishes it or moves to establish it
we can obviously resist accepting his
rhetoric moves to establish it as a
greater war than any other conflict ever
written about i quote facilities of
Athens wrote the war of the
Peloponnesians and the Athenians how
they waged it against each other he
began writing it is very outset in the
expectation this would be a great war
Meghan to assess I and more worthy of
account than any previous ones he based
his judgment on the grounds that both
sides came into the war at the height of
their powers and in a full state of
military readiness and he also saw that
the rest of the Greek world had either
taken sides right at the start or was
now planning to do so this was certainly
the greatest ever upheaval amongst the
Greeks and one which affected a good
part of the Barbarian world to even you
could say most of mankind so a
completely preemptive universal claim to
the greatness of his subject in respect
I continue in respect of the preceding
period and the still remoter past the
length of time that elapsed made it
impossible to ascertain clearly from
what happened but from the evidence I
find I can trust in pushing my inquiries
back as far as possible I judge the
early events were not on the same scale
either as regards their Wars or in other
respects he reinforces that soon after
by saying conceding that although men
always think that the war that they
advert the moment engaged in is the
greatest one and when it's over there
even more impressed by earlier
nevertheless for those who look at the
actual facts this war the one he's
narrating the one I'm narrating in the
voice of the sister dunia narrator will
prove greater than earlier once this
rhetoric of the singular greatness of
the Athena Peloponnesian War is
amplified in another famous passage a
trap 223 of book one of these two
diseases history where he stresses the
unprecedented degree and scale of
suffering characterized in the war I
find this particular passage
particularly suggestive for the way in
which it uses comparison to reiterate or
underscore the idea of incomparable ax t
this particular conflict was
characterized by the fact that people
suffered things unprecedented in any
comparable period of time the sort of
eases calibration of the greatness of
his war and indeed his restore achill
construction of the greatness then
throws down the gauntlet for subsequent
Greek historiography oldest is well
known and much discussed in scholarship
on Thucydides the narrative techniques
that characterized his narration briefly
outlined above are omnipresent when we
turn to the literature of the first
world war in Britain although
grammatically the positive degree of the
adjective in the phrase the Great War
his eye has unmistakable I'm sorry
although when we use the term the phrase
the Great War the the positive degree of
the adjective great is unmarked it has
unmistakable connotations of superlative
pneus the Great War is in a sense the
greatest war and it's because I guess
because of the singularity implied by
the pronoun the Great War as in the
greatest war and we only have to think
about the way in which this nomenclature
has stuck to concede the effectiveness
of the device of rhetorical
amplification in this phrase in so far
as the Thucydides and conception of the
Great War is inherently comparative it
necessarily undercut
itself in facilities this comes through
clearly in book 1 chapter 10 in a famous
hypothetical thought experiment where he
asked his readers to consider what
people of the future would conclude
about Sparta's power in the second half
of the 5th century BCE what would they
conclude about Sparta based on surveying
its archaeological ruins just suppose he
asked his reader the city of Sparta will
wiped out and all that were left were at
shrines and the foundations of its
buildings I think that years later
future generations would find it hard to
believe that its power matched up to its
reputation in entering into comparison
across historical time facilities
engages the impermanence of magnitude in
the present although his war is
allegedly the greatest war ever in terms
of resources deployment of forces events
and consequent fallout as the rhetoric
of the passage that I've just read makes
clear this comparative historical
perspective also implies the contingent
nature of the greatness of the war in
other words all this physical greatness
all the resources being poured into the
war which are spoken about at length in
the first book of the history by the
different states involved all of this
doesn't translate necessarily into
ultimate success in the war that the
acidity Zanda rates it's not the state
athens with the most resources it's not
the greater state in physical terms that
ultimately ends victorious this
observation ties into the acidities is
complex treatment of the instability of
power of Dunamis within the history
lurking behind the statement chapter 10
of book 1 is a famous remark by
Herodotus book one chapter five of his
histories where he says his reader that
he will cover minor and major
settlements equally because those
settlements that were important in the
past have diminished in significance by
now and those which were great in my own
time was small in times past in
Herodotus histories written roughly
contemporaneously with acidities
Athens was a hegemonic power when
Herodotus was writing in the sense that
it was encroaching all over the Greek
world but in Herodotus histories the
version that he chooses to write he goes
back into the past where Athens is a
small state it's small both from the
perspective of the Persians who invade
Greece and it's small and fragile from
the perspective of the other Greek
States who watch many of whom sit on the
sidelines to wait and see how its clash
with Persia will play out Herodotus as
historical research then relies on
criteria of magnitude that are
inherently relative the largest or
greater city or army is only so in
comparison to other cities and armies
past and present following the scholar
Mara Krakowski I would argue that
Herodotus is relative ization of
historical judgments about greatness is
one of the generic traits that
characterizes the emerging genre of
history in the Greek world and it's one
that informs facilities is ironic an
equivocal conception of greatness where
in Thucydides the greatness of the war
is event and subject doesn't reside in
the fragile or contingent greatness of
either of the states involved in the war
this trend in Greek historiography I
think bequeaths an interesting legacy
for a critical tradition of war writing
there's legacy in other words is the
insight that the greatness of the work
will rely in part on the author's
critical detachment and distance from
prevailing conventions or scales of
greatness there's something decidedly
anti epic or anti-heroic about this
strand of war writing and this is long
before we get to the anti heroism of the
disillusioned British first world war
literature i mentioned that facilities
is IRA nization of the greatness of his
great war in which the greatness becomes
increasingly tragic as the narrative
proceeds is suggestive for understanding
the recurrence of irony as a governing
troop in retrospective first world war
literature written in the 1920s and 30s
the further argument that i want to make
on which i can only begin to sketch here
is that the works that have this ironic
structure in british literature are
often ones that are overtly preoccupied
with what I'll call historiographical
ethics the Hound why of the treatment of
the historical past with respect to the
truth or the reality of lived historical
experience although avowedly and
inescapably fictional by its very nature
all First World War literature is
implicated in discourses of truth in
history as George paffett noted in his
book fiction of the First World War men
and women who write about the Great War
are seeking for whatever reasons to
present some kind of truth about a
conflict which was fought in several
theaters across thousands of miles over
several years with vast armies puff it
goes on to observe that this
historically oriented genre results in
interesting hybrid crossings of diary
memoir history biography autobiography
and novel while many scholars and
Parfitt is just one have remarked on the
interpenetration of fact and fiction in
British First World War literature I
think what still remains to be done is
to pay concerted attention to the
systematic hysteria graphic concerns and
the historiographical post-war First
World War literature and I can only
offer a brief sketch of this topic here
I'll do so under three headings firstly
the novelist as historian secondly
discourses of truth and fiction and
thirdly history as monument for the
purposes of comparison with you SID
ities I'd like to tease out how this
group of writers consciously imitate and
sometimes parody historical discourse
these writers are mindful of the
preemptory claims of history to
authority of accounts of the past and
yet they challenge the scope and
legitimacy of historical representation
many of them adopt the pose of the
novelist as historian ap hurvitz novel
the secret battle published in nineteen
19 which is framed as a fictional
biography of a fictional character Harry
Penrose but based on the experience of a
naval sub lieutenant edward diet begins
with the sentence i am going to write
down some of the history of Harry
Penrose the gist of Herbert's novel is a
narrative vindication of an officer who
served in the Gallipoli campaign in 1915
and subsequently did a tour of duty in
the Western Front in France all the
while struggling with nerves and fear
only to be court-martialed and shot for
cowardice for seeking shelter with his
men during a doomed offensive while the
title of Herbert's novel is the secret
history Herbert frequently used sorry
the secret battle Herbert frequently
uses the phrase the secret history in
the novel as a metaphor for his
Vindicator II narrative and in the
closing stages of the novel he sets up
an opposition between the official
judicial procedures of the court-martial
and military history versus the
inaccessible secret history that would
reveal the truth about Harry Penrose is
suffering the role of novelist as
historian is articulated explicitly
rather than implicitly in Herbert
explicitly in Ford Madox Ford's memoir
it was the nightingale published in the
UK in 1933 and the u.s. in 1934
reflecting on the construction of his
famous tetralogy of First World War
models published collectively as
parade's end Ford Madox Ford ruminates
on the inspiration and motivation behind
this 2 trailer G the work that at that
time and now I wanted to see done was
something on an immense scale a little
cloudy an immediate attack but with
salient points and the final impression
extraordinarily clear I wanted the
novelist in fact to appear in his really
proud position as historian of his own
time veera Britain's test for words to
testament of youth published in the same
year 1933 as Ford's memoir presents her
own memoir of the First World War
as an attempt to write history in terms
of personal life and in terms of putting
the life of an ordinary individual in
its niche in contemporary history the
idea that the important literary work to
be done was historical counter narrative
providing an urgent supplement to what
passed for the history of the First
World War resounds throughout all of the
corpus of novels that I'm looking at
here the narrator of Richard alling tins
sardonically entitled death of a hero
published in 1929 offers a cynical
commentary on retrospective histories of
the First World War all this time the
war was drawing steadily nearer probably
it had become certain since nineteen
eleven though most people were taken
quite unaware why did it happen who was
responsible questions which have been
interminably debated already and will
furnish exultant historians with
controversial material for generations
to come or anyone foresees the creation
of chairs in the history of the First
World War to be set up in whatever
civilized countries remain in existence
after the next one alling tins novel
uses many of the same criteria of varied
akala tea and documentary realism as
historical accounts but insists on the
autonomy of fiction this commitment to
the autonomy of fiction is reflected in
Ernest Hemingway's endorsement for
Frederick Manning's 1929 novel the
middle parts of fortune which was
published in nineteen thirty in
unexpurgated form as her privates weed
and I include Frederick Manning he's an
Australian author but he served with in
a British regiment and wrote about the
British experience of the warm in his
introduction to Anna that anthology of
war writing entitled men at war
published in 1942 Hemingway wrote that
her privates we was and I quote the
finest and noblest book of men in war
that I've ever read I read it over once
each year to remember how things really
were so that I will never lie to myself
nor to anyone else about them
Hemingway's artful discourse on the
veranda criticality of fiction
chimes with revived debates about the
fictive pneus of Thucydides as history
that were going on in classical
scholarship at the beginning of the 20th
century in the preface to a work
entitled Thucydides myth hystericus
published in 1907 the scholar Francis
Cornford had written and I quote it's
possible however even for a writer of
history to be something much better than
trustworthy it's possible for a writer
of history to be an artist before
proceeding to expound a notorious
argument about how facilities wrote his
history under the inspiration of Greek
tragedy the most comprehensive imitation
of historical and historiographical
discourse that I've been able to find in
the critical disillusioned literature in
Britain of the First World War occurs in
the forward to vero Britons preface to
her memoir testament of youth we can
subdivide this discourse into a number
of themes and I'll really just read out
sense of the piling up of this
historical discourse in her preface vera
brittain writes about the exact truth
offering some element of truth writing
as truthfully as I could she describes
the burden of her experiences to real
and wants to give a real account to
write about things as they really were
she engages in a lot of
historiographical self-fashioning
presenting the work as an attempt to
write history an attempt to put on
record a contribution to contemporary
history and says that it's backed up by
detached reconstruction and
retrospective reflections above all she
puts it forward to the reader as a
testament she engages in documentary ism
referring to sources on which the
account has made old letters and diaries
documents and records she also speaks
about the value and utility of the work
hoping that she will produce something
that might be of value some elements of
youth usefulness or something worthwhile
she grounds her account in discourses of
memory invoking memory and hoping to
challenge that too easy too comfortable
relapsed into forgetfulness she also
searches for historical meaning
hoping that her Testament will explain
or convey what the First World War meant
to people of her generation that it will
be an exposition of the wars public
significance that it will comment on
worldwide events and finally she has the
address to posterity that we have come
to expect in the historiographical
tradition in the West she speaks of our
successors she speaks at the depleted
generation which has to make the present
an endeavor to mold the future and she
also refers to history's most grievous
repetitions one way of explaining this
piling up and it's I guess much more
prolific than that we find in the other
para tics that a company is this
disillusioned First World War British
literature one way of explaining it
would be to see it in terms of vera
brittain putting forward very
self-consciously a woman's history of
the war and leaning on the authority of
historiographical discourse as a way of
presenting her work in the preface but I
think that's not a fully accurate
because she also intertwines this
discourse with a reminder that this is
her own very private story and she takes
the reader through the genesis of a
testament of youth explaining how in an
earlier iteration it started as a novel
and how she contemplated just
republishing her diaries kept during the
war which was subsequently published
posthumously so she contemplated
republishing her Diaries changing the
names but then says that no she's very
consciously settled for this hybrid form
of a memoir that blends her historical
experience with fiction works that are
either actual or pseudo memoirs
sustained a constant commentary on their
own documentary method would have been
calling documentary ism they frequently
refer to the diaries letters transcripts
and interviews on which they base their
accounts of the First World War
siegfried sassoon 3 part memoir written
in the persona of George sir Stern and
published in 1928 1930 in 1936 is a good
example of this
in the third and last volume of this
series sure stands progress Sassoon's
alter ego George Hurston comments Riley
on a sermon given by an army bishop
reassuring the reader that his version
is accurate because in a spare notebook
I wrote down the main parts of his
sermon so I'm able to transcribe what
might otherwise be accurately
inaccurately remembered insofar as
they're offering alternative versions to
those contained in government reports
these writers fluctuate between a
commitment to the pleura vocality of the
past and a sense that representation of
the war in literature is a zero-sum game
in 1933 vera brittain commented on the
boom in war literature and described her
own intervention in publishing her
testament as a late entry into the field
in the preface to his memoir of the
First World War entitled undertones of
war published in 1928 Edwin Blondin
asked his address see why should I not
write it where the pronoun it denotes
both his accounts the volume that the
reader is reading and the war of which
it is an account another pronoun is
important here too in blunden
declaration the authorial in naira
torial I why when so many other literary
figures had turned their hand to writing
the war should blonde and be excluded
not least among these figures of course
was the poet Wilfred own whose poems
blundin would edit for a new collection
that would appear in 1931 London's first
sentence why should I not write it
rehearses the problematic of war writing
what I've called the historiographical
ethics and we encounter the same
problematic at the beginning of
facilities as history phuket Adair
Hassan I Osasuna grabs it on polym on
facilities the Athenian wrote the war
the Peloponnesians and the Athenians to
write the war is simultaneously to
record it and in the process of writing
to distort it to substitute a textual
version of the war for the unreadable
totality of the war and the
appearances of all who lived through it
and who died in it but as the elite
linguistic turn in historiography has
made abundantly clear there's no war
without narration even the it in blond
ins why should I not right it is already
pre written and pre narrated as Hayden
white remarks they historical entities
become historical only to the extent to
which they are represented as subjects
of a specifically historical kind of
writing blunden himself got involved in
the polemics about which version of the
war was most representative attacking
robert graves autobiographical memoir
goodbye to all that published in 1929 as
a misleading and vicious debunking of
honest soldiery and the values that
blunden himself identified with the rank
and file of the British Army in the
First World War in his biography of
Edmund Blunden Barry Webb describes an
evening specifically the 7th of November
1929 where siegfried sassoon and Edmund
blundin sat down together an annotated
blond ins manuscript copy of graves as
goodbye to all that with marginal
Corrections and criticisms this
manuscript is now in the burgh
collection of new york public library
there was also a private copy that
belonged to see Preet Sassoon with his
annotations which sold privately at
auction in 2007 so that's a particularly
explicit version of the polemics of the
historiographical ethics of the first
world war while unable to see and
predict the Second World War these
novels and memoirs a time sensitive in
the sense that they fear the recurrence
of war and decry the possibility that
future generations might suffer what
their generation had suffered they all
seek in their different ways to hand on
a warning and testimony to the next
generation and to an indefinite and
obscure posterity Ford Madox Ford writes
that in undertaking parade's end he went
against his own bias against novels
written with a purpose seeking to write
a work i'm quoting to
right of work that should have for its
purpose the obviating of all future Wars
the facility in claim that the acidities
set down his account of the war between
the Athenians and the Peloponnesians to
be an everlasting possession iktara SI
ay is one that resonates strongly with
the concerns of these critical first
world war writers in the study of war
imagined samuel hines examined the troop
of anti monuments in pessimistic British
First World War literature what is
interesting to me about this an amount
of anti monumental aunty monumental ISM
that Heinz describes is that on the one
hand it offers a savage critique of
official forms of commemoration while at
the same time holding itself forward as
a more appropriate monument to the
experience of individual men and women
the preface to Richard olding tins book
death of a hero published in 1929
declares his work as really a threnody a
memorial in its ineffective way to a
generation which hoped much strove
honestly and suffered deeply in the
first pages of the novel the narrator
reproduces the casualty list citation
for his fictional protagonist George
Winterbourne commenting sardonically
that Winterbourne got his meat ration of
headstone in France and then proceeds to
contest the value and relevance of the
official record of George's death I
quote all intan narrator I can't claim
that I'd set up any altar to the
deceased George in my heart but I truly
believe that I'm the only person left
alive who ever thinks of him before
exploding a few pages later the death of
a hero what mockery what bloody can't
what sickening putrid can't they're all
so fascinating instances in this
critical pessimistic British First World
War literature where the alternative
monuments of fiction are endorsed as
true monuments by public figures ap
Herbert's the secret battle which I've
already mentioned published in nineteen
19 was reissued in 1929
mine with a preface by Winston Churchill
which endorsed the fictional biography
of Harry Penrose as and i quote a
monument to the agony not of one but of
millions standing impassive in marble to
give its message to all Wayfarers who
pass it speaks to the uninformed to the
unimaginative to the headstrong and to
the short memory folk who need a word of
warning on their path as Elizabeth
vandiver has shown there's a paradox
about British First World War literature
and its relationship with classics on
the one hand there are copious allusions
to Greek and Roman classical literature
which I haven't been talking about here
and these illusions indicate the extent
to which classical myths and literature
were used to respond to experiences of
warfare but at the same time in this
literature there's a deep distrust and
cynicism about the usefulness and
relevance of classics for the present
day more than that there's a suspicion
of the malign influence of classics in
the present day in the early decades of
the 20th century as vera brittain puts
it in her memoir and not quoting exactly
but paraphrasing of her experience of
being an undergraduate at oxford before
she left to become a voluntary age
division nurse in the Western Front why
spend so much time translating Caesar
and other passages of Latin about people
killing each other when one's
compatriots are killing each other
within a hundred and fifty miles of
where you're doing the translation but
the same vera brittain also turns in her
memoir at several instances to Homeric
epic as a source of consolation for the
loss of her fiance in the law war and
later for the loss of her brother in
many instances elsewhere officers in the
British Army are characterized by their
intellectual complacency where a shallow
and imperfect knowledge of Latin is used
as a pretext for superior learning I
quote an example from Frederick
Manning's her privates we where an
officer called Evans is described as
educated pre-war public schoolboy which
means that he remembered half a dozen
Latin tags could mumble a few
ungrammatical phrases in French knew a
little history of England and had a
correct accent this passage i think is
typical of the deep suspicion of the
role that classics might have had
ensuring up the idiocies and hypocrisy
'he's of the governing classes in
britain and what were perceived as
failures in military intelligence in the
field but as with vera britain's
ambiguous attitude to classics ancient
Greek authors also in this literature
provide a source of creative inspiration
and counter myths to rival contemporary
historical fictions for all Newton
blunden Britain Ford Herbert and Sassoon
the question of the continuing
significance of classics was also a way
of confronting the significance and
meaning of their own times and their
recent historical experience in the
light of history the memoirs novels that
I've been talking about contemplate
their own relation to the past often
returning to the distant past of
classical antiquity and insofar as they
offer their own account of a past war to
future readers they also insert
themselves into this historical relay as
well and this raises the question that
if the classics of antiquity and the
works that recount them are outmoded and
debunked in the present day what are the
stakes are implications for their own
versions of a past war projected into
the future I'll end with an example and
it's my only example in this talk of an
explicit few City anism in British First
World War literature this comes from guy
Chapman's novel a passionate prodigality
fragments of autobiography published in
1933 this autobiographical novel ends in
disgust with complete contempt for
British society and the apparent aims of
the war and it expresses disillusionment
in the form of a quotation in Greek very
unusual in British First World War
literature to have a non translated
quotation this quotation comes from
facilities is me
in dialogue from book 5 with acidities
as history where athenian envoy's are
depicted spelling out athens aggressive
Imperial aims to the millions from the
island of Melos who were trying to
resist incorporation into Athens as
Empire the line that Chatwin quotes is
from Thucydides book 5 chapter 91 and I
quote from Jeremy my knots translation
this is the Athenian speaking well as
for this Empire of ours if that came to
an end we would not be too daunted by
its passing the threat to the defeated
comes not from other ruling powers like
the Spartans though our dispute here is
not with them but from their subjects
should they be the ones to take on their
former masters and get the upper hand on
the last page of his novel Chapman
writes our civilization was being torn
in pieces before our eyes England was
said to be a country fit only for profit
ears to live in s did it will pro
slacker dime on us hem in Oregon many of
us were growing bitter thank
Thank Emily would welcome discussion or
questions Chris that was the beginning
of the one about the nominee but Harry
yes sounds similar fashion the secret
battle sounds actually like a quotation
of the beginning of facilities oh you're
right if there was a sense of which the
prologues of some of these historical
novels engage purposes could you try to
repeat the question yes and so the
question here from Professor cross when
i called up that slide showing the
beginning of HB Herbert's the secret
battle where the narrator says i'm going
to write something of the history of
Harry Penrose yes that's if you leave
aside the preface from Churchill which
was added later in a way is more
comparable to facilities I think that's
what you're suggesting because the
preface is embedded in the main work
rather than being a para text in the
form of a prologue and some of these
works have several prologues yeah I
think that's right and in my attempt to
sort of try and sketch this dialogue
between facilities and this corpus of
literature I've obviously been stressing
points of contact rather than in
commencer abilities by calling this talk
how to write a war I don't want to imply
in any way that the acidities is
normative for a metal genre of war
literature I think the fascinating thing
is the other part of the conversation
how when we turn to this particular
corpus we could also look at
contemporary war writing
the ways in which the authors negotiate
the strategies of narration of war right
back to facilities and expose what he
chooses not to do and the lack of
preface a--'s parrot X that we we
wrestle with in looking at ancient
literature you know call to mind the
sort of huge sense of golf and in
comparability gesture of acidity
suggested what what her mind is writing
is a is a fragment is a is a partial is
a very tiny part which fits with the
idea these novels as looking at a person
Vera bringing herself just rather than
trying to write the greatest war just a
little bit of the history yes good and I
think they're the tension then becomes
between the singularity of the story and
its strong authoritative claims to
representation or X and priority that it
can be extrapolated or multiplied out to
speak for millions and you know again
the way in which you put that question
reminds us of the fact that the
acidities is a person in the war he
writes it in some sense on the authority
of having been a general and yet that
person disappears in his account of the
war acidities describes himself as two
different people in his own account
are there any figures who are comparable
to two lucida T's and having had
significant contact with both sides for
example thinking of being of the German
names that you see in the lists of war
dead in British universities who
returned home to play against thee
against the British art is there any
literature comparable in a specific
sense of having been but written by
somebody who actually has significant
contact with both sides in this role in
the case of First World War see more
accomplished can you just say the
question so um professor bears has asked
to what extent in this sort of and this
is my admission the corpus that I've
been talking about is a very very
limited collection of post-war novels
and memoirs looking back on the First
World War which I've treated as a sort
of particular corpus because they are
linked by the sort of disillusionment
with which they approach the war and
because many of the writers are in
conversation with each other and
conscious of each other's work in this
corpus that I've been talking about are
there any examples of authors who likes
acidities claim to have had exposure to
different sides in the war not in the
ones that I've been talking about that
doesn't mean they don't exist not that I
know of the only analogy I can think of
is the way in which contact or touch or
encounters with enemy combatants make it
into the novels as a way of not showing
up objectivity Thucydides uses that
claim to say in 526 I saw the war from
both sides that's part of the authority
and impartiality of my account we don't
get that same stake played out in this
body of literature other than that an
encounter with the enemy sort of
reiterates the sense of the absurdity in
it
see of the conflict of killing people
who in the encounter revealed to be as
human as you in the movie in Gandhi is
young where there's the beating of
English aristocracy well with the with
the chief of the the German I forget the
name of the character very famous actor
that is where they are in a way saying
we belong to the same class but now
things are really different and you have
for example to the German the German
officer speaks English breaks from the
french text and there's that sort of
goodbye to all that mean that the notion
that group type of transnational union
of people of a certain class yeah I mean
I'm not sure exactly ought to do that
question which I take more as an
observation but I I think that one of
the legacies if I'm thinking critically
now of thinking about facilities as a
model of critical war literature is the
homogeneity of his focus on the
narration of a war that although he
talks about having seen the war from
different sides you no one can sort of
vocalize his narrative quite clearly
through the Athenian perspective and as
you know there's a strong tendency to
play down those who fought with the
Athenians but were not Athenians the
role of slaves from all over the Greek
world and Beyond in the conflict and
hear that in contemporary critical
historical accounts of the First World
War is work that's near only laterally
being done in thinking about the broader
spheres of empire and the ways in which
subjects are occluded in these accounts
you get sketches and vignettes of
foreigners it was a not british french
belgium german austrian but foreigners
from the empire in these novels mystic
question I I was struck in the passage
you mentioned facilities use of
superlatives perhaps exaggerated
superlatives making it seem as though
this was unprecedented when we know that
it really wasn't but I was struck by a
passage in the book one chapter 23
excerpt never before were so many made
men made exiles never before was there
so much slaughter which includes the
front I don't know whether this is
facilities or am I not but but what
strikes me is the front of negative
adverb and the inversion and the scale
or the so many all of which emphasize
this you know compare comparison with
everything that has ever come before and
what it made me immediately think of was
the famous line of a world war one
historian in middle of World War two
never in the field of human conflict was
so much owed by so so many to so few
which involves exactly the same
construction and I wonder whether of
that any of that was actually in the
syntax in the facilities passage or
whether that was my knots intervention
in the translation um I mean off the top
of my head from what I remember about
that passage in Greek acidities 123 you
do have in the Greek that very stylized
negation which is a trope of of Greek
rhetoric and you know your comparison
with with was with Churchill and his
sort of negative try colon in that
famous speech yeah I mean one could
think they're not just about fictional
accounts of the war but relays within
military rhetoric within the battlefield
and Churchill's use their 1940 yes um
reclaiming yeah and I didn't need to say
that facilities in that particular
instance is using it ironically I mean
this is part of his strong rhetorical
claim that this is the most important
war that has ever taken place in the
world to this point but I was suggesting
that that then is undermined or begins
to crumble when you look elsewhere in
his histories at his consciousness of
the contingency and and relative ization
of powers in the broader sweep of
history you know it's very artificial in
many ways to do this kind of a historic
size comparison that I'm doing with you
SID ities and this group of British
First World War writers one could
equally think about the way in which say
Shakespeare is used as a companion text
for thinking about the experience of war
Frederick Manning's her privates we
every chapter is prefaced with an
epitaph from Shakespeare and you there
as well in this broader project on
comparing facilities I'm interested in
XO T Tauri battle rhetoric in
Shakespeare's history plays and the ways
in which they rehearse tropes rhetorical
exercises from antiquity about the kinds
of speeches that you give on the field
in battle you know we have many examples
of those from the-- acidities as well
and in the writers who I've been looking
at the British First World War writers
one can look at ways in which they
consciously parody there's rhetorical
models and examples and yet are
themselves invested in the same
rhetorical structure
well that last question sorry um i just
i'd like to try to like push back
against the suitability of these writers
need wars for comparison i just wonder
how you would fit industrialization into
your analysis I mean lucida T's is
making the case for this is the greatest
board that's ever happened and yet wars
that fallout after it probably resemble
pretty pretty closely for a long time
whereas the wars that follow the First
World War are fundamentally
characteristically different from the
wars that preceded due largely to the
large kind of scale industrial
technology the revolutions in the means
of destruction and killing and part of
puzzles kind of main point is that this
industrialization fundamentally changes
the ways in which wars can be talked
about in the ways it can be remembered
and then I kind of how does this how
does this kind of point fit into your
analysis I okay thank you so the
question is to what extent does the the
sort of shift in the military-industrial
progression of warfare in the 20th
century from the first world war into
subsequent conflicts how does that pose
a problem for this sort of a historical
comparison that I'm doing with the war
that Thucydides covers and the writers
writing about the First World War I'm
very interested in that question and I
thought a lot about it in relation to
Daniel pics book the war machine where
he talks about comparative histories of
warfare in the art of war and challenges
the idea that the First World War and
the Second World War posed a sort of
radical paradigm shift in terms of
thinking critically about the history of
warfare I mean obviously I want to
respect the difference in terms of
military technologies and conceptions of
warfare but yet at the same time these
authors who I'm discussing contain lots
of episodes in which characters in the
field of battle are in gay
in these very same questions you know at
the start of the war in 1914 where you
have Kings regulations dispatches sent
out to the field of battle telling you
to practice a battle formation or a
strategy that is maybe remembered from
the burl war or from a war prior to that
and then catching up as the war proceeds
but some of them I'm thinking
particularly of a character general
Campion in the second novel in Ford's
trichology for aids end that novel is no
more parades has this rant where he
writes a letter from the field of battle
back to the Secretary of War in London
trying to insist that you know in spite
of all the differences between all the
wars there are some points of good
generalship that remain constant in
terms of the need for a sort of singular
vision or good channels of communication
so I agree with your point and your your
sort of challenge to what I've been
saying other than to say that I don't
think its final or decisive this is part
of a negotiation that is going on in
this literature inserting itself into
this relay of writing about war and
thinking about where the differences are
so I'd like to invite you to continue
this conversation at a reception in the
common room which is just a few steps
down the hall and I'd also like to thank
Emily for a wonderful seminar today
thank you
you